secretary of state mike pompeo says
possible military options
are on the table to counter reported
aggression from
iran the pentagon plans to release
photos it says
supports its case that iran was behind
last week's attack on oil tankers in the
gulf of oman
david martin is at the pentagon david
what will these photos
show us exactly good morning the
u.s officials say the photos will show
remnants
of one of those mines they believe was
planted on these tankers by
the iranian navy the pentagon plans to
use these photos to persuade still
skeptical
allies to join the trump
administration's campaign
of maximum pressure against iran
the world needs to unite against this
threat from the islamic republic of iran
on face the nation secretary of state
mike pompeo
argued iran is to blame for the second
attack on oil
tankers in the gulf of oman in a month
the crew of one of the stricken tankers
allegedly hit by iranian mines
arrived in the united arab emirates over
the weekend
and would become witnesses in the case
i'm confident that as we continue to
develop the fact pattern
countries around the world will not only
accept the basic facts which i think are
indisputable
but we'll come to understand that this
is an important mission for the world
u.s officials say the iranian navy tried
to prevent the u.s from gathering
evidence after the attacks thursday
eight minutes after the first distress
call an american drone was overhead
25 minutes later the iranians tried but
failed to shoot it down
when the second tanker was hit by
explosions the american destroyer
bainbridge immediately headed in its
direction
but according to this pentagon document
an iranian patrol boat attempted to
block it
hours later another uranium boat came
alongside the stricken tanker and
removed what u.s officials say
is an unexploded mine attached to the
hull
although this video has left many
countries unconvinced
democratic congressman adam schiff
agrees with the intelligence assessment
we should be trying to corral a response
though from the international community
to protect shipping
to impose sanctions but because we have
so alienated ourselves from our allies
that's not happening the u.s is working
on plans to
provide better protection for persian
gulf shipping
plans which could involve sending
thousands more troops
for its part iran announced overnight it
will soon have
more uranium uranium stockpiled
than was permitted under a nuclear
agreement it's signed with the
obama administration adriana david thank
you